within the past day a recorded increase
of more than 1900 people
diagnosed with the virus the i-team's
vanessa murphy is live with more on the
state's efforts to try and get the virus
under control
vanessa
we may be hearing from governor sislek
over the next few days about new
guidelines
it is likely we will not have another
shutdown
at this point but possibly additional
restrictions
the state's positivity rate is fifteen
point eight percent
five percent and above is considered too
high now caleb
cage is the state's covid covid 19
response director
he says there are encouraging signs that
the public is taking stay at home
2.0 seriously but the numbers are still
concerning
while hospitalizations in the northern
part of the state went down here in
southern nevada they're going
up there's a strain on the health care
system here so
making sure there's enough space with
licensed beds and even getting enough
health care workers
are challenges the problem is right now
that
we have we're competing nationally with
with other states because we have a
nationwide
surge going on right now which is
different from the regional surges we've
seen in the past
there's a call for volunteers through
the battleborn medical corps for people
who may have a public health background
or experience working in a lab
we'll put a link at eight newsnow dot
com and as governor sisilak and state
health officials
consider how to address this surge here
in nevada
you know they have to consider balancing
the economy and also
public health again they will we're
hearing try to avoid a shutdown
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now